what yeah
hey guys what's up this is Dave failed
I'm Kate Quigley I have my sometimes
co-host and lovely BFF Jen Sturge are
here what yes and all the enthusiasm
that's one has much I'm on like seven
adderall by the way in case I seem a
little jacked up and a coffee and a
sudafed so things are great things are
really good friends like I couldn't be
on the opposite or different spectrum
harder to six of iced coffee no text
Brian today I'm like can we push back to
2:30 I had a feeling you wouldn't mind
so I know that was an extra snooze I
know and guys my guest today a very good
friend of mine you may know him from the
Joe Rogan experience or just from his
stand-up or from his millions I feel
like you've had a million podcast the
all the death squad death squad shows I
should have worn my death squad shirt
today I'm sure I'll take a selfie in it
later
Brian red band everyone so seeing you
guys again it's always good to see you
you know my favorite people he really is
now y'all y'all girlfriend it up you
know I know you're like an adorable
teddy bear that talks about buttholes
kinds of other stuff but you're our
favorite anywhere no as though you're so
just like cuddling hugging lists you
know I used to liked about talked about
buttholes and all that stuff until I
started dating an asian girl and then I
realized oh they age ins love but holds
and all that stuff a million times more
than me I mean [ __ ] my girlfriend's the
most like she talks too much about it
like she's sending me photos of her poop
cause it looks fluffy like and I'm like
no is your hair with hair with your
girlfriend sent you photos of poo yeah I
mean I thought it was I thought it was
cool that we could balance and I thought
I thought it was cool cuz we get fart in
front of each other but lately she's
like I like to smell your farts and oh
my god you're not supposed to say that
now it doesn't work if you mark if I
think you're delicious
Oh
discuss how on the last episode we just
talked about how the the porn guy that I
was dating for a while got like
basically gave me [ __ ] because he
thought it was weird that I was like
sending him like dirty photos and like
flirty text and he was like I just think
it's weird like most girls don't send so
many of these like it's not normal did
the guy also do boy seams
no I will say that one night I was with
that guy and I said something like how
um my friend found out her her boyfriend
was gay and he was like how do you know
and I said like well she caught him
[ __ ] a transvestite and he was like
was it really gay
if he has like tits and so there you go
there you just answered your own
question open once you open the door
crack yeah right doors over here right
you need to change that guy's contact
the [ __ ] dick yeah and is that yet
changing that one what's his icon gonna
be but that's so funny of that like he's
giving me [ __ ] for that meanwhile
Brian's girlfriend is sending photos of
food yeah like what perfect bridges
[ __ ] dick
she's the one she is so dope though cuz
I know she's great I love her so much
and I follow you of course on Instagram
and the other day he posted an Instagram
story and it's literally just her
outside just [ __ ] bouncing on a pogo
stick and giggling hysterically and like
she I don't think she knew a single
Asian never watch she's addicted to pogo
sticks and and Mike and she's like did
you find work and she's been practicing
every day and when she first got it she
was just I could do like a couple now
she could go super high ups and now it
she giggles hysterically because he
can't believe how high she's going now
or go sticking is she high wall doing
this yeah sometimes
hey it's amazing watching her gross a
pogo stick err I mean you're like does
any of these skills translate to the
bedroom because otherwise this seems
like a pretty useless skill set really I
could already throw off me and like err
you know I occurred in the kitchen she's
so tiny I mean I have to say the pogo
stick thing though is such a good
workout when I was just in a DC randomly
some dude I can't remember his name
there's a comic who did like a guest
spot and he had a pogo stick in his
trunk when he broke I did I broke it
yeah yeah I broke it but that's beside
the point
Brian uh I kicked it because it wasn't
working right and then I broke off one
of the foot pieces
it wasn't an expensive one okay but the
point is I bounced on it just for like
30 seconds and I was sweating so I would
imagine if you got great at it it would
be a great you don't know what this
conversation was about that was a
hilarious statement it's an amazing
workout it's hers though like is it like
one of the cheapy ones or like it's like
made mid-price Amazon like I think it
was like 50 bucks which is like I guess
expensive in the Pogo market you know
you pogo mark I didn't either but I feel
like Brian you just seem to go on Amazon
and just order all kinds of weird [ __ ] I
had [ __ ] to my basket all day long like
like I you know people were giving these
chickens I have a wish list and I'm like
like I think Sam triply brought it up
like any anyone any comic that's not a
porn star that has a wish list needs to
be shot or something like something like
that there's a way to say Sam I have a
wish list it's just like having things
that like a real wish list like I want
this I want this you don't have time to
buy something right I'll come back and
buy this later
that's hilarious that Sam said that
though because like like maybe two years
ago Sam was like I can't believe you
don't have a Amazon why don't you have
an Amazon wish list and I was like cuz I
feel weird because I'm not like a porn
star are the only people I know who do a
piece or get it yeah are porn stars but
sometimes people will ask me they're
like why don't you have one and I just
here's what it is cuz I'm broke as [ __ ]
all the time but you don't even want the
perception that you're asking people for
crap I feel like if you're on TV too the
rest of
world they think you have money so then
if you're like hey I have this wish list
and I'm my wish this would be like gas
groceries like that's why I would yeah
the hour oh don't even get me in started
with power bill like I suck at paying
bills like I feel like I'm one of those
guys that like every two months I'll beg
oh how much I owe all right I'll pay it
you know and I pay all the extra late
charges yeah I'm like the worst at
paying bills but I live in Burbank where
they have their own power company
Electric Company and so they they are
they don't work the same way as everyone
else like if you're like 15 days late to
your build they just turn it off and
like you out of nowhere just got no
power then it costs like 150 dollars to
turn it back on then you have to pay
this month's bill last month bill in the
future bill like it's like $700 if you
get your power turned they just turn it
off in two weeks yeah time you get yeah
it's ridiculous that's crazy
so I'll forget like oh and I'll just be
sitting there I'll wake up and I'll hear
just like my ceiling fan turn off I'm
like no please no don't let it be then I
go run outside and I look forward like
my first like light outside like yeah it
is a light bulb go out use it [ __ ] it's
the worst wait so how long does it take
for them to turn it back on now it's all
electric like they literally press a
button which makes it even more sad that
that guy doesn't have to drive out there
so you're not you're paying what am i
paying $150 for for you to push a button
so now it's a it's portal and if you
don't have money you're [ __ ]
like like I try I've been where I had no
money like I've had like $300 I'm like I
don't have $700 and like we're sorry you
know yeah at least have to have $450 I
took off the $50 thing here but I'm like
Jesus no way ticket that's crazy
sometimes I just pay the minimum like
I've never done that before in my life
I've always been like a payoff the whole
thing all the time person but lately
I've been just paying the minimums on
things that I didn't even know you could
like did you know on your cell phone
bill you can just pay like 50 bucks to
just keep it going for like you could
stop you can rack up five grand worth of
cell phone bills and just keep paying 50
bucks at a time yeah I'm lucky though I
mean since I switched to t-mobile
yeah like my cellphone bills not a
problem yeah it's a used to be a problem
absolute [ __ ] what well it depends where
you live like I definitely like we live
in the top of a mountain it's amazing
Brian and I have argued about this
forever because I'm Verizon in your
t-mobile and my bill is astronaut it's
like $240 or like 30 bucks isn't your
something like that it's on the yen we
yeah why I have two lines and unlimited
everything and I think it's under a
hundred bucks
yeah it's with me with with an iPhone in
it you know I'm paying for this on top
of unlimited everything for a hundred
bucks yeah something we're doing a
commercial but what but for real
well you got t-mobile Tuesday's which is
you want me to adopt you and put you on
my family plan yeah oh my god you should
do that you know what you should do if
she doesn't even do that which she
should cuz like you could pay her 30
bucks a month and that she'll make money
off this and then we're and then when
you're in one of your moods I can just
turn your traffic - yeah you could track
her like angry texted me oh my gosh oh
this [ __ ] baby great to bazooka block
numbers of guys I shouldn't be texting
and I wouldn't even know and I'll be
like why is this [ __ ] texting me back
and Jen's is like so weird I mean should
really they're getting all your texts
right you should really just go to like
if you don't believe us just go get a
phone get a new sword as a team level
try it for 10 days if you don't like it
take it back but I bet you it's gonna be
better service and half your bill we
should not talk about team oh yeah no
but that was its approval care because
everybody out there has a different cell
phone provider and it is true that
Verizon kind of sucks lately like I also
have verizon insurance and I [ __ ]
just broke my phone a couple weeks ago
and when I want to get a new one they
were like it's going to take two weeks
and I was like why am i paying ten bucks
a month or whatever for insurance if
it's gonna take two weeks and they're
paying $200 to replace my phone screen
and didn't even use my insurance so [ __ ]
Verizon yeah I hope your ads and doesn't
isn't a sponsor of many podcasts I'm
happy now I I mean I came from Verizon
also so like it nowadays they're all
exactly the same like that's stupid
Sprint commercial where like they're all
within 1% oh like
cuz it's totally different than it used
to be two years ago so nowadays it
doesn't matter it's just who's the
cheapest one now it is yep I'm glad we
had this talk
people need to know everyone just make
the switch I'm gonna make the sweat
we're all gonna make it an iPhone don't
let that Samsung why
what are you okay but why won't first of
all I really do like Samsung because
there are things I use my stylus for I
have a note and I use the stylus I color
on things and I use it for like writing
and signing I use the stylus that's one
and also the cameras better and the
cameras better the camera is really good
you haven't played with a seven plus
with the two cameras in the portrait
mode in the light the low-light I have
your exact same phone so I know I have
both oh you do yeah alright and also you
can get you can curve your phone just
got her and you can just get a [ __ ]
you can use that as your drawing pad on
the side you have a service to use it as
a drawing pad he's got a point
that's good point all right fine I'm
gonna switch everything okay your eyes
it is a gift no just let Brian among
your life this I really feel like I
should have done that a long time ago um
okay let's let's talk about that this is
funny how we met how Brian and I met I
don't know if Jen even knows not worried
because I think it's before I met you
again so Brian I met at the Comedy Store
and we bonded over being from Ohio
because you're from seabus right yep see
buzz new boss and I'm from Canton and so
we we hit it off and I was like oh this
guy's so cool I love him we should
totally hang out he's like we should
hang out and then we hung out a bunch
yeah we started going on a lot of dates
they weren't dates you maybe they're
just guys were hanging out so I was like
hey we should go get some food together
sometimes for me and her wit had food
and drinks multiple dogs wait can I was
any like making out yeah well Panda
nothing can I say my defense first of
all that I did say I don't take comics
right up front all right now you say
don't date you're trying not to take
comics anymore Oh trying not to date cuz
and then and then you used to have this
picture that used to send everyone but
you wouldn't send it to me because you
liked items I don't know you just have a
picture you sent to a few people not
like I want to see it and you're like I
don't send Ellie the friend zone rule
okay I thought we did say that because
I've said that to so many this is true
okay this is true I have a rule with my
guy friends like where say I'm not
dating anyone and I take a hot photo and
I have no one to send it to sometimes
you just you're drunk and you just want
a little you know validation so I have a
rule of my guy friends were like they
can have the hot photos but once you get
one if we've never [ __ ] your friend
zone for life that's the rule yeah
because like it take it we're just were
just don't want there to be any like
confusion so if you get those from me it
means you're in the friend zone forever
so and I said well I don't want that
picture and we continue to go on date
and then Instagram and then Instagram
came and she's like I'll spit them here
instead ya know whatever so okay well
yeah I guess I'd to be fair to you
that's kind of like my way of getting
out of sending guys nude photos to is
like I'm like oh then you're in the
friend zone forever and I did kind of
dig you like I just didn't want to [ __ ]
around with the comics I didn't want to
[ __ ] [ __ ] up but I also kind of like did
like you so it was complicated and then
I took her to a concert I think it was
Jimmy Kimmel we saw Nine Inch Nails it's
really funny like backstage I think that
was no no nothing
that was the one he did take me out like
four or five times and really he was
super sweet such a gentleman always paid
pick me up naturally Kate thought he was
a friend and then that was the one so
then he took me to Nine Inch Nails yeah
and then I think it was after that
concert where I was just like I I'm done
wasting my time yeah you know so I think
I start dating somebody else like
quickly after I was like alright goodbye
the best thing though is he at least
like he called me out on it cuz I
remember cuz he goes yo I takin you out
like five times are we gonna make out or
what
I know that was my exact but it sounds
like it's like that you know like make
out with me or what and I was like what
these aren't dates I told you I just
wanted to be friends cuz you're a comic
and he was like he's like I [ __ ] took
you out I paid for you I took it like he
was just arguing about this yeah well
it's definitely you have [ __ ] all
backwards I do I really do and if she
did say like the friend thing like she's
not trying to date comics then maybe
that was like the first date we went on
first time we went out or somebody vo
your dates it might've been the first
time but it wasn't like every time hangs
I do want to say two things one I was
very naive but at the time too when I
met you to be fair to me like I don't
even single for like a grand total in my
life at that point of like three months
or something Wow
cuz I got right out of my marriage I
dated a guy for a year and then right
after that I I dated like that comic for
a very brief moment which is why I was
like and on a date comics it's not going
to be so I was so just dumb and naive
that I really now of course you taught
me a valuable lesson which is like now I
really don't even I don't ever let guys
pay for anything if I'm not if I'm not
like oh I'm gonna date this guy it's not
and it's not like we became enemies or
thing we were friends so after day I
just would call her out like oh what are
you gonna do now hold his hand like any
time she's talking about it like I was
just kind of like give me ur little
little things like you know about now
he's a trained her so hard
Brian you trained her so hard that she
doesn't let dudes pay for anything even
ones that she's trying to date well I
don't have day I'm dating loss yeah for
what I let him pay but I just get
nervous about them thinking that I'm in
it for the wrong reason so I'm really
careful you weren't expecting her to do
any of this you were doing it because
you liked her yeah but you weren't like
okay the Nine Inch Nails concert she's
gotta [ __ ] me Road Dogg no no it was
never laughing it was never like that it
was just more like - I know
something's gonna happen ads are i right
nothing's yeah and i never gonna be good
friends and pretty much when i said that
to her
like it was more like hey man i'm giving
up you know like i'm not it wasn't like
dear mu i hate you' boring it was more
like i give up i'm going to go this way
now but then to show what an amazing guy
brian is we did always still stay
friends and like it's so funny too
because i think that you are so
different than the way that people like
perceive you because you have this whole
like death squad image which is like i
thought for real
I have a pain and Reichel yeah 100%
which is funny because I still have you
saved in my phone as Brian Michael and
people are like who's that and I'm like
oh that's red bad but like it is funny
because I thought too that you would be
this dude that's like [ __ ] all these
porn chicks all the time and just like
super dirty and kind of a dude and
you're like the nicest sweetest well
read ban is what the pole [ __ ]
importance I dated a porn star so did
everyone fight oh he's [ __ ] all these
porn chicks just because I was hanging
out with all these porn stars alright
relate yep so then then and then me
being like like all the stories that
I've said on like on all the different
podcasts and stuff that's me just being
read band version of all those stories I
left I would sit you down be like yes
this did happen but wasn't as crazy as
you think you know it's like there's
definitely an exaggeration when it comes
to right there when it comes to everyone
everybody has that why I was talking
about that on the last episode how like
I feel like my kind of like image or
branding or whatever because of that
guys expect a certain thing and then
when they get to know me and I'm
actually like nor not normal but like
chill and like kind of sweet like girly
insensitive no well yeah when you're
well your Instagram is all like hot sex
hot sex buttholes you know like I see
where they're coming from interesting
pictures of your butthole no she puts
like a flower over it to be fair to me I
really only post like maybe one in like
ten photos that's like even remotely
sexy and I've really scaled back on how
hot they are you don't even know that
they're sexy though like you have a
picture of you like wearing a sweatshirt
like going dude be sexy while you could
see like the outline of a nipple through
your sweatshirt meanwhile guys were cool
well that's not my fault
now you too it's not your fault yes
that's true
your fault I allowed to pee yeah you go
pee brother make a pee break go take a
pee on your feet
but you are Michael you intercom red
banjos red baby that was red bad for
sure you're gonna miss Brian [ __ ]
story cuz that's what I'm gonna ask him
about okay you know what we'll talk
about until she gets back instead of
[ __ ] let's talk about VR okay you're
so into v.i.c
it's vr gaming that you're doing yeah I
got the new PlayStation VR so lately one
of my favorite things to do is like at
night I'll come home and I'll invite
somebody over afterwards and we'll just
play video games all night because it's
it's it's like doing a drug for your
first time if you do it proper like a
good VR system like it's like the next
day you're like wow I feel different now
like it's no intense experience last
night like I played it so long that the
next day I was like laying in bed when I
woke up and I was looking at my screen
it was a picture of Obama and I swear to
god it was an animated gif but then I
like like squinting my eyes and like
like shook my head and looked at again
it was just a photo like it was [ __ ]
with my arm makes you see we are I think
when you first start do it it definitely
your brains not used to it your eyes are
not used to it and I think it's a couple
days it starts getting used to it but
for the first couple of days I was like
it was like doing mushrooms your first
time then next day like going you know I
see Leafs different you know I'm looking
at a tree and it looks different
okay well I can kind of relate cuz we
shot um I host a show called undercover
on the Playboy channel and we explore
like weird sex stuff and one of the
episodes we did was a VR porn episode
and so it was a two-parter like one part
of it we went to the real doll factory
in San Diego so lucky
have you ever been there no I would love
to go I've that's one of the things I've
always wanted is a real doll
because I really have so many mannequins
and like robots and stuff like that oh
yeah
I'll hook you up with them they would
love you oh love to be yeah yeah yeah I
will take the refurbished ones yeah did
the real girl factory is crazy because
you walk downstairs and it looks like
you know this scene from Rocky Roy walks
in and all the like chicken carcasses or
not chick whatever meat carcasses are
hanging and you like pizza it looks like
that but it's all like [ __ ] all body
but just the bodies with no head yeah
that's it's I've seen it before it's
it's I mean like on the internet but
it's that's I love real real da sir yes
so cool and calm it's crazy they gave me
a real dick that's a prototype of the
new real dick they're making how's it
feel real it's the most it feels so real
it's crazy and it's like literally the
perfect it is like the most perfect dick
like when they make this thing and it's
usable and it's attached because that's
what they're doing is they're they're
making it so that when you wear the VR
headset and you watch the VR porn you'll
be able to use your real perfect yeah so
you'll literally think you're [ __ ] a
real person
perfect that's awesome yeah now did they
give you a big one or I gave you a
little one like it's it's like eight
inches like what was your waterline on
that I have to see you you can see where
like there's like powder where you know
as I've been used before and then
there's just like this cleaner version
of it halfway through I actually haven't
used it your new staff no [ __ ] I
swear to you I haven't used it like that
because it's so like nice and pretty and
perfect now what a magical weapon your
[ __ ] I had it on my coffee table in the
living room so that would be what would
come over they'd just be like what the
[ __ ] is that I'm a suction cup or
anything it doesn't suction but it
stands up nicely just stands up nice
that's hilarious but uh do you watch
we're talking about VR porn Jen oh God
so have you used the VR headset for porn
it's the PlayStation VR so they don't
have easy access to the VR porn stuff
you have to you can actually do it one
of the bigger websites I forget which
one you can download all their VR onto
like a thumb drive and then hit put it
into the PlayStation so there is a way
to do it yeah I haven't done it yet
because but I've done like the city of
the girlfriend Yeah right but I'd have
done I have the done the Samsung memory
where you put it in like the little
thing and use your phone and yeah what's
crazy is that I thought I've been
talking about how I thought porn is dead
for a while I think my cams have pretty
much taken over and like unfortunately I
don't see any porn stars anymore and I
didn't really see any kind of hope for
but after watching my first fear anymore
parents didn't either so after watching
the art porn otherwise in VR porn I was
like finally I get it like this is their
way back in because after you watch VR
porn for your first time you have a
connection even though it's not like
you're [ __ ] a person yet and it was
like a shitty version of the are porn
that I was doing it was still close
enough where I was like that was awesome
like I thought that was way closer than
watching on a video that to the point if
I watched a better version of I could
see oh no there's a whole new wave of
porn coming you know it is crazy so we
for this episode on the porn on the VR
porn we went to a set and I got to be
the body in one of these VR porns like I
had clothes on but if you like so you've
done it so if you are the person wearing
the body the phone at home the headset
like if you look down you see a body
right so it's if your dude you can watch
one where it's a dude body and the chick
is like on use or whatever well this is
a girl-on-girl one and I'm the girl's
body so the other night I'm at The
Improv and I'm talking to oh I shouldn't
call him Atticus I'm talking to a comic
friend Josh Martin Josh Martin yeah
about the VR porn and he's going on and
on about how amazing the VR porn is and
how much he loves it and I was like oh
my god I was in one of those on this
site called VR bangers you can't see my
face you can see my body he [ __ ]
pulls out his phone he goes what's it
called I have a bunch of them downloaded
on my phone and I go it's called which I
didn't know this it's called
downward-facing [ __ ] down Wow or
downward [ __ ] something like that and
that the chick is like doing yoga and
then she starts like coming on to me
right so he pulls it up on his phone and
it's there and I'd never seen it before
and then I got to see like what it looks
like through his heads captor closed on
the whole time so yeah I'm just I'm
literally wearing a dress and so my job
and these these porn guys that do this
job they sit it's crazy they sit on a
couch and basically the camera is
mounted in front of where your face
would be so you
have your head tilted back you can't see
anything the whole time so I'm just
laying there not moving but if you have
the headset on you look down it's me I
have on like a purple dress and it's
like my legs and my body oh man that's
so cool in that crazy now so confused on
word [ __ ] just if you guys have the are
bangers you can go see it I can't
believe him giving them a free plug for
this but I I'm gonna watch that tonight
you should ha ha girl isn't it was
really cute I ain't gonna look down and
be like god I have great boobs finally
yes I Kim and I will give up I will give
it yeah great tits I will give a
shout-out to that that girl because it
was like her first week working and porn
and she was so nervous and she did a
really good job Jill would you remember
her name I don't you know I was watching
some yoke you just normal yoga videos
like like the sexy yoga videos yeah I
love yoga like those yoga pants you
don't even need to see them naked I love
it when it starts sweating around the
crotch
that's high like there's there's porn
videos I forget what it's called it's
called I don't know what it is where
it's like girls masturbating with yoga
pants on and it's just you could just
see how wet they're getting because
their front of their pants starts
getting wet and that's the hot part like
you can't even see anything you just see
their pants getting wetter and wetter
and wetter this cannot that is hot I
mean I had a guy the other day tell me
that like oh I really am into like girls
that have on like sexy outfits like a
like when girls send me like photos of
them in sexy outfits instead of nudes
like it's hotter like there's still
something about like leaving something
to the imagination oh absolutely
that's why my Instagram doesn't have
nudes right that's cuz you'll get bad or
you'll get bad yeah well that too isn't
that weird that Twitter does not give a
flying [ __ ] about anything but you know
they don't yeah it's like why Whitter I
don't know well a lot of people say
twitter is basically like for porn at
this point that like a lot of people
just have twitter to follow porn stars
and see naked you don't even need to
watch porn if you follow a porn star
yeah I had to mute I'd actually mute
like all the porn stars I follow because
when I'm on airplanes and stuff I'm
scrolling my Twitter feeds just one job
that's great idea I need I haven't used
the mute feature that much because I was
just
the same thing like even though I enjoy
saying all this like you're just
flipping through and so you see a girl
getting [ __ ] in the ass like a gif
okay you know again it's like a lot of
times like you know I'll just be sitting
there and like my girlfriend we would
like watch me and it looks like I'm just
looking at porn like a porn website yeah
oh through my timeline it's awkward too
if you're sitting next like an old lady
on an airplane or something it's just
it's awkward and I don't want to deal
with that uh so I'm I heard a story
about you the other day um that had to
do with [ __ ] and apparently my
podcast has turned into the place where
people share they're [ __ ] their
pants stories now three should he make
people feel so safe I think they can
talk about that safe place
um but Brian I heard a really good story
about you [ __ ] your pants at a store
well it was on purpose is um per I
talked about this in my act so I I'm
sure a lot of people have heard this if
they've seen me do comedy but it pretty
much I dated this girl which was a lot
younger and she bought me a box of
depends as a joke and I like her already
yeah I think it was and I don't think it
was depends I think it was like dollar
store depends like she just went to the
dollar store and bought a shitload of
stupid stuff perfect you know typical
stoner dollar store move and she she
wrapped it up in everything as like a
present and I was like I'm a gift and I
opened I was equipped to work but then I
have this thing where like like I don't
want to throw it away now like I'm just
what I want to waste it you know so I
thought that for a couple like a week or
so and then one day I was gonna use I
was like you know I'm just gonna try one
on she's at work who gives a [ __ ] so I
tried went on cuz just to see if it
worked and just to see if it worked
yeah but one thing I didn't think of it
was like really sweaty and it felt like
I was wearing a diaper like it was not
like a good version of depends like it
was like it seemed like a older style
model or something do you think that
actually were Hansa veil well the dollar
store
do you think actually weren't like good
diapers and you're just like taking the
risk of [ __ ] your pants
well generic that's what I'm saying well
it seemed like [ __ ] your pants like you
better have some reliable stuff well I
didn't really like like I'm gonna take a
dog what happened is you're kinda like
if it happens it happens well kind of
like I had him on for a couple hours and
oh that was sit down to do it or East it
no I was standing I was at Target
and I remember eight a second you're at
Target
how dare you shouldn't pay good stores
Church
I got Brian what the [ __ ] and see I
wasn't [ __ ] I was just like every
time I farted I just didn't have that
extra like muscle squeeze to make sure
nothing comes out Oh like was like a boy
how many times you fought on average
when you drink as much as idea you fart
a lot yeah I mean okay yeah I know I
mean like I there was a few times where
I farted and I just remember like I'm
not I'm just going all out because I
know I have these diapers on bad well
it's interesting
like something's creepy your whole life
your whole life you've never liked all
right you'll they if you're gonna give a
good fart you there's still a little
like 20% muscle that's like making sure
there's nothing coming now right your
fingers like hold the door guys
oh the door I mean the only time I enjoy
farting is when I'm in the shower you
know because then you're like you don't
give a [ __ ] and like I'll even [ __ ] I'll
cut my hand around my butthole ah god I
better fill with water so does Donald
Duck next time you're in a shower think
of you know you're gonna fart
cut your hand around your butthole let
it fill up water and blow it out it
sounds like Donald Duck fucking's like I
have a poor man's hot tub okay can I say
hot dog night after Brian's been
drinking and he's just sitting in a tub
with his girl she's like turn up the
bubbles he's like oh can I just say like
on the last episode we talked about how
this guy was dating said he wished I was
more normal and I was like I wear
bikinis the DMV and tell stories about
[ __ ] my pants like you're getting
you're not getting nor
but like this makes me feel really good
to know that Brian cups water in his
hand over his [ __ ] and farts in the
showers because I realized that the mind
of any artist is [ __ ] weird like
that's what no normal person would ever
be like I'm gonna try to make Donald
okay we have Mr guys after you ate the
cheeseburger in the shower
oh no yeah I've been doing the Donald
Duck my whole life like that's like my
whole legs like he was growing upon me
he was a simple grown-up with me all
right so so Margot and I blow a fart and
it was totally like whoa and I was like
yeah that was some came out there but
the problem is that it smelled like I
smelled it like immediately like it was
like a fart that just stuck to me I was
like and then I kind of freaked out cuz
I was like oh my god oh wait [ __ ] there
wasn't [ __ ] in it no there was [ __ ] in
it you did [ __ ] yeah just a little shark
a shark a shark but it was pretty bad
like its yelled it smelled and then then
I was like I was like near the the
furniture like in target yeah and I had
to like let go through the whole entire
store and go to the bathroom and like
throw it away because it was like the
most
smelled like I [ __ ] my pants oh yeah as
you theoretically tried to write but I
didn't think like I didn't think for
some reason I thought oh you know if I
[ __ ] no one's gonna know that's the
whole cool thing oh you don't think you
think I think that when you got when it
gets wet it would smell like something
like flowers or something but no it
smelled like [ __ ] so I was flowers well
I didn't know I did not the diaper when
it gets wet magically smells like fly I
just didn't figure what smell like I did
not even that even know long denied we
know when babies crap themselves I don't
like this is for adults you know so like
when it's smell like licorice well it
should that should that makes sense
actually have you looked into it since
then to see if real depends it on a
dollar have that feature no but I think
there is w every potpourri potpourri
poop poop vector burgers yeah that's
always different smells like tropical
blend and like oh my god like pizza roll
flea
I buy your lorry smelled like pizza I
remember its it really smelled like the
worst kind of dog poop that's what it
smelled like they yet they orange yeah
me kind like they good golden tree ver
poop that's what it smelled like
it was bad and it was very noticeable
like I thought it was just me and I
thought it farted so I started walking
real fast try to escape it
it was just following me like worried
that anyone's gonna get out and like get
down your leg like no I know it did it
felt like I mean cuz there was like the
one that I had on was like kind of like
elastic like it felt it felt like I was
protected tight but uh it just smelled
really bad
did you pee in it no I would have tried
peeing him no I threw them all away
after that was a dead [ __ ] this like I
almost I was don't you like ours gross
but this is too much I think do you live
in LA that's not a bad investment to
keep some in your car cuz I'm drunk on
the 405 so [ __ ] long you gonna have
he in a diaper like let's be real huh
have you peed in one of those Starbuck
no no no I I peed a lot in my car but I
only use like the big mouth like
Mountain Dew like the big Mountain Dews
with the big mouth you know so a bottle
oh so you can literally just like attach
it on in the back I think yeah
and because I usually have like that or
the Arizona iced teas used to or that
the metal I guess the glass ones yeah
glass Arizona I think they're Arizona
but yeah not only usually have a couple
bottles my car so being a zombie that's
what we deal is there so be lizard
that's right and the bad thing is that
it usually it's more than one those
bottles so you actually have to stop it
and then like Oh had me stop yeah Oh
usually gets you to enough though to
like a gas station or something but I've
done one of these once and I learned my
lesson immediately because I filled the
whole thing up it's renta uh you know
how much you pee I only pee I don't pee
that much so when I do pee it's like
alright everyone out you guys don't pee
like guys I know guys at pee like you do
yeah and it's mostly because you have a
problem you know Oh old like that old or
they just have prostate problems you
know you know huh this has taken an
interesting turn that I didn't expect
like just looking out that the date you
went on yet the gay date yeah
should we get Brian's advice allocating
you should I think if anyone's gonna
give you an honest opinion all right I
took a lot of [ __ ] for talking about
this online okay but here's the thing I
went on my first bumble date God last
week I've never been on a bumble Fox
well can I just say by the way like an
actual it was like you know when
something's so bad it was a bumble bug I
came home drunk one night and lonely
it's the whole this time of year makes
gonna kill mice like I think single
girls this time of year we need to like
band together
yes [ __ ] holidays I feel it's guys
awesome and like usually I'm single for
Thanksgiving and Christmas like the last
three years I've been like my
relationships I've ended right before
yeah my presents for anyway yeah but
you're also sitting at home by yourself
is your family's away and you're eating
lean pockets on Thanksgiving and then on
Christmas you just sleep because you
don't want anymore tight yeah I think
are you gonna text you last Christmas
like what are you doing and you're like
sleeping all day or something yeah like
it's the [ __ ] worst so one night I
came home and I got on bumble and I was
like [ __ ] it I need to go on I need to
start dating like I just need cuz I
don't date really much so I got her just
swipe it everywhere I [ __ ] I'm at like
50 guys and they send them all just a
high high high high and then a few
message me back and there was one he was
really hot older 47 which I like order
got his [ __ ] together he's a surfer
great body I'm like oh this looks
promising and he looks like really butch
like in his photos like that's kind of
my my type I tend to go for like butch
lookin dudes I know Brian you think it's
do you think they're gross but anyway so
I match this dude and we start messaging
and he's funny which is so rare you know
like I go uh hey I'm free to get a drink
on Thursday night and he's like oh well
Thursday night I have plans get my
eyebrows waxed but I guess I can move
that and I'm like oh my god that's so
funny that's hilarious cuz he's this
butch looking guy talking about getting
his eyebrows waxed you know and then
like we make plans to meet and I'm like
on my way to the bar and I'm like okay
I'm I'm wearing jeans and a gray t-shirt
just in case you don't recognize me I've
super dressed up clearly by the way and
then he's like okay great I'm the one in
the unicorn suit and I'm like oh this
guy's funny like he's
like what likes that would be like a
fighter guy being like I'm in a unicorn
like you don't expect that so I thought
this is all good signs and then I walk
into the bar he's like hi I see him and
he stands up and he goes hey so good to
meet you like just like that and
immediately I'm like is this guy K and I
don't wanna make immediate like snap
judgements but he like most straight
guys aren't that flaming right so then I
sit down and uh he's like you know what
can I get you to drink and I'm like um
I'll just do like a tequila soda and
he's like girl the some mixology bar you
can't do that he's a girl
he said girl oh then that's it but today
I'm over but no I mean I know guys that
act gay like that people think are games
I get one things 20-inch Chris gay and I
like his whole life he's he has jokes
about it luckily it's really funny but
he's not you know like look but but if
he was to say girl or something like
that
then it's the chick is help and then but
here's what here's where it gets even
weirder cuz I'm trying to hang in there
cuz I'm trying open mics I'm really am
trying to change the way that I date
like I don't want to keep dating dicks
like I wanna date a nice guy right so
I'm like I'm gonna give this guy a
chance cuz you know he seems nice and
he's here so [ __ ] so then like he
goes um oh keeps making really sexual
innuendos at me but like in the gay boys
like he goes uh I told him I had to
leave at 11:30 because I had a set at
midnight at the Laugh Factory and he's
like what you mean this isn't a sex date
oh it's like uh my favorite texter sent
me was yeah girl you know I'm gonna
watch that ass when you walk to the
bathroom
I did I said I'm gonna go use the
bathroom when he goes yeah girl you know
I'm gonna watch that ass when you walk
away and I'm like it's confusing good
wonder where you got those pants cuz oh
my god say that and that's a problem is
everything was like borderline gay
alright so dude here's my three theories
so far so far one the guy is gay - the
guy is by three it's LA he's somehow
trolling you
and like there's a camera a nurse friend
sitting next to you recorded I mean I
guess that's possible kiss him no oh I
couldn't he also he looked like he'd had
a like work done on his face Mike and
Lenny at one point he goes everyone in
this bar is so hot I just want to make
out with everyone here I spy starting
with those two and his points at these
two dudes who were so gross looking like
so I think he's making a joke I said are
you gay I couldn't I just said check out
these guys at the party points to a guy
guy are you gay by the way I should have
why you scared your comic okay yeah I
mean this was somebody in the audience
would have called this person I know
because on a date I'm different you
should approach every date like you're
doing crowd work I think I hold back on
dance I'm afraid to let them see my real
that will mean this yeah this goes back
to your problem I think hey intimacy
issues
yeah well so could then the next day he
texts me and invited me over to watch
football
was it soccer he's like I'm having a
question having people over to watch the
Patriots I would have gone over just to
get the vibe of the room I would have
not gotten over I would have wrote that
guy off as being bi or gay and not
interested because like even if you're
coming over to his house you're not
going to be attracted to somebody that's
that flamboyant no pressure so you
should just stop don't waste it with my
mom is I hate when people waste people's
time yes you know it's it's like just
tell me immediately if you're just bored
and yeah you know what I mean yeah I
don't want to hang out with the ladies
when you know it's just bored you know I
agree but here's a question that so then
I did that so I message John and said
hey what do you think I should do and
invited me over and Jen said I think you
should date him a little more for
material that was Jen's answer well you
got that route that's I I didn't want to
do that though cuz even though that's a
good idea but I don't want to I don't
want to waste this time and it's mean
like I try not to be I don't be mean so
but here's the question what I did is I
just didn't answer which I never
normally do and do you think it's nicer
to just say I had a nice time
I'm just not interested or is it easier
for the guy if the girl just never
replies and you get the hint absolutely
say I'm not interested
oh really yeah because when a when you
don't text me back it makes the person
think well maybe she didn't get it maybe
you know maybe she's not doing that
makes you text more then it makes you
become crazy because you'll go like a
month later I'll be drunk going on
whatever happened to that girl she never
want me back oh and then you're texting
out at 2:00 in the morning you know it
just kind of makes you be the worst guy
you know instead of you just going like
hey man I had a great time you know what
I just don't think me and you are gonna
work out but you know hopefully we can
stay friends but and then just don't
ever talk I like that advice that's what
I'm gonna do next time I just didn't
answer I should even his text after
though he was like because I want to do
a set that night and then the next day
his texted me as he goes did you make
him laugh and I wrote back yet went
really well
and he wrote excellent work my dear and
I was like who writes that like it's so
my dad my dear
all right well then we got that I will
from now on just say I'm not interested
I just don't like to hurt people's
feelings but I guess not answering is
just as bad yeah I mean i-i've been on I
haven't done too much of the tinder
dating or anything I think I've done one
yeah I've done one and we're still
friends and you know Lily it was cool
like we hung out a few times but I
didn't hook up yeah but I knew it wasn't
I know it wasn't going to work out
because she had a huge dog and she had
to carry bring her dog everywhere so
like she brought her dog to my house I
was like God now there's just like 500
pounds I saved a bigger dog is this one
of those girls I had to bring her dog
she's like if you want me to stay over I
can't bring my dog or I can't leave my
dog in my house I'm like all right so it
was just so much like little things like
that that bug like I like it when you go
in it might not be a thing between me
and her but it's something like it's a
lot easier if I'd have to deal with this
you know like it's actually has dog
problems like she can't talk oh just
bring a dog everywhere she works you
know maybe it's her emotional support
animal oh wait yeah but there was just
so many things like like she worked like
an hour away so actually when she gets
in chatsworth is new right away I just
knew like the things weren't adding up
but we're friends Annette you know we
want a few dates and everything and it
was fine it was chill but
I've never done like a lot of my friends
this just hook up you know like I'm just
going to go tinder hook up hook that
really works like who are these girl it
would never in my wildest dreams occur
to me even no matter I'm like the
horniest person I would never go on
tinder and be like I'm just gonna [ __ ]
some stranger tonight like I think it's
so weird I think I'd have the friends
that I used that I know have used tinder
and stuff I think all of the music for
just hooking up but like who are the
girls are they getting like hot girls
off here uh yeah what they at what's the
average like a six or seven it's seven
yeah I'd say like well I mean I haven't
seen all the girls look like it's a fact
my friends have asked you know but uh
you know the girl that I met was
beautiful but you know it's just what it
was beautiful and she's just down to
[ __ ] that night no not that night we
went on a few days oh you looked up the
phone that first night now I've never
done that like it's it I've might my
first night meeting hook up ratio is
like a zero on Madison yeah yeah yeah I
don't like doing that it's just I'm way
shyer than then yeah yeah I mean like
I'm not gonna be the guy that gets you
wasted and immediately just starts
trying to [ __ ] you like not a no be
physical and stuff I'm more like red bag
wasted and it may be like oh whoa that's
the end of the night or so yeah no
totally
yeah no you're definitely you're
definitely not that go home with red man
you wake up with Michael making your
pancakes is way have you ever had a girl
be like I know you for a while I feel
like you would fly in people
yeah you've no I've already flown in
you're an importer yeah yeah I what I
used to have pretty decent money coming
in you know yeah you know from making
t-shirts and stuff like that so at the
time I was single so I went to Japan and
then you got a girlfriend all your money
goes away oh yeah but I went to Japan
and met a girl from Japan and we just
became friends and then she's like
always used to talk like send me
messages like oh I wish we could go to
United States so I let's go under how
much it is to you know it was like six
hundred bucks round trip oh wow
so I was like you know once you come and
she stayed for like a month and we just
hung out for a month this come almost
complete stranger I met in Tokyo
I flew in and we had a great time for a
month and I flew back and we're Sprint's
again to this day Kate he flew a girl
from Tokyo and you can't get a free
drink
do we see what the problem is Jen this
isn't about me it's about Brian saying I
I'm a huge now I this wouldn't be
happening if I live in Columbus Ohio you
know the problem is that I have a big
problem with a lot of the girls that are
in Los Angeles they want to be actresses
they want to be this and that
especially when I'm like a podcast
producer and and stuff like that I feel
like people talk to me a lot just to to
get ya you know their motives yeah
they're like fake ass people and I run
in these this [ __ ] hat all the time even
people that have known for years I'll
find out the whole time that they're
just like a fake-ass friend yeah so
flying in people especially from Texas
which is where my favorite women in the
road fly in a lot of Texans yeah I left
I love Texas Texas women are the best
women in the road like that that's just
how they're raised like they're they
take care of them so they're beautiful
they're just nice people like what are
some of the nicest people are so uh
flying in from somebody Texas to go on a
few dates and hang out for a few days
way better than going on a date with
some la actress that wants to make it
like so because they're real people and
you tend to get to know them first over
like webcam or you guys talk guys this
is one girl that I dated for four four
years and I met her in Texas when I was
doing shows and I would fly her in once
a month and we would talk every day nine
hours a day to the point where my ear
was burnt like sunburned from just my
holding it on my phone like it was like
crazy but then after like six months of
flying her in I was just like you want
to live with me she moved to LA live
with me for four years yeah and we dated
for four years you know what in some
ways though I'm judging but I mean
that's basically what happened me too
I'm like that is absurd I know and she's
like I know my boy on Twitter yeah I
mean but in some ways and this happened
with you and Cody too and there was like
the guy I never ended up dating him but
there was the guy in Philly that I was
talking to a bunch and it's like in some
ways I feel like you almost feel closer
and get to know someone better when
you're talking to them long distance
because it takes all the sex out of it
and
but comes like do I actually enjoy
talking this person do we have a lot in
common and then when they do come to see
you it's like you already have this
intimacy that takes forever to build up
oh yeah you know them so well by the
time they get to you yeah because you've
been talking eight hours a day
Skype everything and you're just sitting
there pretty much biography
like telling them sort it takes
everything out of the equation except
conversation you know yeah but now do
what I do it again no I hate long
distance relationships because they're
so raw I've been through a few and it's
torture and you know and then when that
person goes back then there's like
jealousy things so you're like where's
why is she not answering your phone
tonight and then you start become like
jealous boyfriend that lives 6,000 miles
away yeah and you're just like it's it's
it's I think it can be and I'm not I
don't mean this for you but like when I
was married my ex was a musician and he
would be away probably 60% of the time
and I think that it can become unhealthy
also because it's like then when they
come back you want to you want them cut
like you want to be so with them because
you know you're not going to see them
again so you're together 24/7 and then
they leave yeah and then there's
separation anxiety when they leave
because there's suddenly this person is
gone and it's just so emotional it's
such an emotional rollercoaster I think
not for not for me though I'm like go do
something Cody's good he'll be gone for
like six seven months he comes back he's
home for like two days and I'm like can
you get a hobby or something baby snow
job I don't care you miss him like crazy
when he's gone sometimes but sometimes
I'm like I enjoy I enjoy being alone
sometimes you mean this is a good point
though I think so that I can fart in my
hand in the tub and make no [ __ ] up
I need kidding I think Jen likes peanut
oil more than your a girlfriend guy like
you love having a girl I love having a
girlfriend hundred percent and but let
me say that when I'm single and dating
that's a lot of fun and boy do I drink a
lot enjoy and I spent a lot of money
like every night I'm cuz I'll be
somebody like if I'm single I'll go have
a date monday date Tuesday yeah yeah
and and then it'd be like four girls
that I'm just like figuring out who I
like the best or whatever but I'll go on
a date every single night I don't like
doing that
like after after like a month that's
like I'm so sick of going out on date I
just want somebody just to lay here then
you pick one right do these girls all
know that they're like on The Bachelor
without knowing it because I'm very I
think I think these are more also dates
like we're like I don't I think like out
one girl go on a date like once a week
with you know if she thinks that it's
like more serious than that then it
would not be once a week yeah I mean
yeah but no I mean like this last round
before I met toe like there's a few
girls that I was just like going on
dates with and a lot of them but there
was one that I really liked a lot yeah
but you know it just wasn't matching up
you know you hang out and go have a
great night but it was also kind of like
yeah she doesn't she's not like in it
for like a relationship yeah it's just
like whatever so no and then when I met
toe it was so funny after after my toe
we literally like she moved into my
house like a week later yeah you guys
are so cute yeah this is a great match
it was like oh this is a perfect match
yeah you guys are perfect together um we
don't have a lot of time left but I do
always make everyone tell a bad date
story on this show which you I feel I'm
sure you have lots of bad date stories I
I remember you fly already said it crazy
he thought he was dating you I look
besides me those are obvious no but I
mean like I remember you flying in like
a super crazy [ __ ] like I know you've
got to have some I gotta start to date
stories perfect
uh which one do I want it she can tell
both all right I'll do one that's real
quick one girl on Twitter I met oh you
know I've already told this one a
million times that's okay let me think
of a better one hold on take your time
yeah talk for a second I have lots of
bad ones I could give I could give more
about ones you could write a book I
could write a [ __ ] book no it's time
by going okay perfect okay so I met this
girl so beautiful like she was like a
super much she looked exactly like
that one girl that was [ __ ] I can't
remember name but she looked like like a
famous actress Oh to a tee I'm almost at
the point where I first I was like wait
a second at the Alba girl Jessica Alba
I'm did she look exactly like her and so
hot uh she just she's way I call an LA
[ __ ] which I there's a lot of them out
here and you it takes you a while to
figure out if they're now like in LA
gypsy is they don't really have a house
or they say they're staying with a
friend okay but they're really just
going from one boyfriend's house to
another so you know once they find
somebody they'll meet watch it and watch
on your relationship and next thing you
know they're just living at your hotting
what yeah anyway and then you know then
after that happens for like a month or
two yeah they're like I get the rest of
my stuff at from my friend's house he
find out that's her ex-boyfriend friend
yeah
and so she's what she called that like
like she was staying at some guy's house
and then she started staying at my house
every single day and then one day she's
like I have to get my stuff for your
norm and just can I keep some stuff here
like okay anyway so this girl very
beautiful and she just hung out with me
all the time and she and then she was
always like awake that she never go to
bed and so like the after like the
second time hanging out she just started
coming to my house a lot I'm like
alright this girl's hot and she's cool
but she never wants to go to bed and I'd
go to sleep I'm like she's like I just
wanna play video games I you know and
I'll be like our emergency cam Girling
from no no no and then like I would wake
up at like 10 a.m. and she's still
playing video games I'm like why is she
still awake and then she's am was she
trying not to fuss so no no no so then
after like a couple days of I mean this
is like just going on a date next thing
you know she's staying at my house like
then after a couple days I was like yeah
are you going to get out of here you
know like it like you know cutaway
nicely ass is [ __ ] to me yeah did this
I mean this dates lasted please dating
11 some stranger things camping out in
the [ __ ] room
she builds a fort yeah she was luckily
she was chill and so pretty that I
didn't care that she was just staying at
my house hey can i play with this is
like now mentioned that she's hot like
20 tight like that's all it takes
remember I mean she wasn't high she was
a seven yeah like [ __ ] time well be
like why is she in my but but if there's
a supermodel oh yeah you could just do
it do you want you Nene got you this
cheese plate after a couple days after
our date I was like alright I gotta go
to work now I don't really trust you
enough to just keep you at my house
while I'm not here you know kind of
thing so thank you so she can gig a pet
hey [ __ ] said she was going to get her
stuff from her friends and stay there
for a couple of days and so I'm like
okay next thing I know she moves back to
her home state which was like Kentucky
or something like that
I sure AM ik what the [ __ ] happened here
and she's like not texting me back and
like what that I heard she just said
someone moving back to Kentucky talk to
you later
like I'm like what the hell and then and
then like a couple months later she
calls me up and she goes by the way I
have something I need to tell you I was
addicted to heroin and uh oh my god I
would go to your inner your bathroom and
just shoot up and then stay no wonder
she know her subs holy [ __ ] so she's
actually a heroine at it yeah living in
your apartment there's a lot of drug
addicts that actually live it like look
I own a drug addict well I mean like
like like you don't really people really
do heroin like likes it like there's a
lot of yeah you're around you're like
you have no idea that I would you never
know like I'll do you know mushrooms
every six months I'll do coke every
couple months yeah but like nothing
crazy like I'm not like addicted to
anything but there's girls are people
that have serious drug addictions that
hold their [ __ ] together so well you
would never would never know there's
have been a few people that are like
yeah I'm addicted to meth and what you
you know [ __ ] like that you're right
it's your machine that's falling out of
there yeah he's like I had no idea
especially in this town oh it's like all
these celebrities people like how do you
stay in shape and they're just like
genetics
like is that code word for cocaine
because there's no what nobody is doing
it by genetics it's just I mean you
talked about vicodin early every girl I
know adderall I'm not I get it to be
clear my drug of choice yeah every every
girl I know is on a derp although like
yeah it's like ridiculous I had have had
three adderall's my whole life and the
other day somebody gave me one yeah and
I split it in half and I should find the
other half but like that little half I
was like wow this I felt great I can see
why people like this you know like I'm
awake and my brains working that's all I
know I knew you didn't do it off in the
night I saw you at the Comedy Store it's
like midnight Brian's like I got matter
on him like we will be up for two days
right now I took half of that night oh I
didn't take the other half like it's
still in my front jacket of my coat
that's how I am with it like I don't
take it off in any more because I I
found for me it really does help like I
have really bad a DD and it really does
help me focus but when I run out because
I don't have health insurance so I'm
like buying illegally and when I run out
the crash from it is insane I mean I
can't think sure I'll go on set one
night I went on that's how I knew I had
to quit one night I went on set at the
ice house and I seriously like could
barely remember my jokes I mean my brain
just like wouldn't [ __ ] work and I
was like oh that's it like when it
starts [ __ ] with my comedy that's
what's funny is like you I'll let guys
treat me like [ __ ] I'll let all this you
magic show but you mess with my comedy
I'm like oh [ __ ] no like that's it
yeah I remember back in the day I'd some
coke before going on snow I tried the
first time I tried a adderall I went on
stage and I took like a whole pill and a
couple hours later I went did an open
mic or whatever yeah and I remember
thinking it's like a gun and they're
like you got 7 more minutes right but I
remember feeling I was on stage like I
felt like I was on cocaine I don't know
my guy was getting drips and stuff and I
was like I'm never doing adderall again
like that made me like [ __ ] up yeah
and then I tried adderall like the
second time a couple years later and I
took half I was like I could see this is
good if I need to do something important
like I know right deadlines yeah I
didn't write but yeah it's a tool I
think I was great but a lot of the
people I know like there's people that
would text me
the 4:00 in the morning I need a duro
did you know anyone that can sew at her
are like Jesus you're like it is so
addictive because you start getting so
much [ __ ] done and also I find for me
that like I was kind of using it as not
an antidepressant but it helps regulate
my emotions I can be really sensitive
and I know when I when I'm on adderall
I'm not as quite as impulsive when it
comes to emotions I don't text as crazy
I'm not like a tour uber focus I am yeah
so I don't get it distract it with like
oh this guy's not text me like I don't
care it's weird but I don't like how it
makes me on stage because I noticed it
makes me a little edgy the way Oh timing
off yeah it really does and so so guys
tomorrow today don't you drugs don't
wear diapers at Target and try to take
shits don't import strangers unless
you've talked to them a lot don't date
heroin there's no getting long-distance
relationships yeah if you cut it off
early cut anyway don't even get that go
there yeah don't do drugs and don't take
me out thinking that you're dating me if
I say that we're friends and I think
that's it yeah because there's a lot
today cuz the gamut um Brian this will
be up not tomorrow but next Friday so
anything you want to plug you got coming
up I got a bunch of new I have a whole
new t-shirt line and sweatshirt line and
hat line that's probably gonna be
dropping next week so yeah it's gonna
drop in like a turkey target yeah so
shop squad TV shop squad TV making like
a school 7-eleven hat and remember the
7-eleven hat yeah we have the same one
I think somebody stole mine but ah uh
yeah so just like I have these hats like
this is a McDonald's I noticed yeah I
was staring at it the whole time I
people think like Japanese McDonald's
it's a desk what happen to look like my
god so I'm making a 7-eleven one right
now which is a sweet sweet I love that
you make dope [ __ ] you really do and
that's quite a TV death squad TV follow
Redman if you don't I'm sure you do at
red band Jen uh you're at the nevermind
that's this weekend what do you got
going on dude I don't even know what I'm
doing just for Jen
sorry follow me and all my adventures at
Jennifer serger following me at cake q
funny this has been date fails tweet me
your questions or you can email date
fails pod at gmail.com see you guys next
time bye
dude the